it is the being that clarifies what is
important and what is not such that you
can bring a presence and a mindfulness
to the doing by placing your attention
on this thing that aligns with your
values you know that that doing is
worthy of the being that you're bringing
to it
today by Roca I'm off 20 off your order
with the code richroll roca.com
[Music]
check check check see if this mic works
it's been since May since we've done one
of these Adam we're back after an
extended Hiatus interrupted with a few
mini docs and monologues but the people
have spoken Adam and here we are back
with roll on hotly anticipated for the
hardcore fans good to be here man thanks
for having me yeah man it's good to see
you uh we're a little rusty unsure on
unsure footing about what we're going to
talk about today uh but I'm excited
there's a little there I can feel the
anticipation yes yeah I feel it as
always you know we're gonna
shoot some [__] maybe answer a couple
listener questions but we do have a
special announcement we're going to make
and we have a special guest yes
begrudgingly is going to be joining us
after the break and his name is Chris
Evans not Captain America I would say
captain UK he is the broadcasting legend
himself host of the Chris Evans
breakfast show on uh Virgin Radio every
morning broadcasting from London he's
been a huge supporter of this show he's
on vacation here in Los Angeles and like
if we're doing roll-on we got to bring
the guy on oh yeah so we're we're
forcing him out of exactly vacation he
wanted to watch but we're not going to
allow that so he's going to be coming on
after the break in the meantime our
voicemail again is
805-421-0057 if you like your question
answered on air you can leave it there
for a future roll-on episode whenever
that's gonna happen I love it yeah man
so let's do the check-in uh you know
what it's good to be here I've been
missing you I miss being here I was at
the beach not too long ago with the
family you know I'm at the beach of the
family a lot and I thought of I saw the
way our water founts are being treated
and I wanted to start just unpack the
water fountain situation so this woman
comes along with her dog
the dog is thirsty it's hot out and she
brings it right to the water fountain
and turns on the water it's not the
first time I've seen this in Santa
Monica turns on the water fountain the
dog hops up and starts lapping out of
the water fountain
and so this is this I I go into this
immediate like I have like one of those
go into my brain and I'm thinking this
is like a David Goggins moment where
even the dogs in Santa Monica don't have
the dog in them and I texted him this
afterwards it used to be when we were
kids we would like we those things were
oases we would play really hard we'd go
over there we'd drink out of them some
kids would like lick on them we'd still
then drink after them it wouldn't even
matter to us and now everyone has the
little bottle and has their perfect
water and the dogs even won't drink out
of the gutter the dogs used to be happy
with the gutter water what is happening
to our society you set that to Goggins
what did he say he said oh man it's all
[__] up that's why I'm out here smoke
jumping so basically what you're saying
is this is the death of civilization in
an anecdote right in a nutshell the dog
you know refusing to drink water as
given right the gutter water is not good
enough for the dog the water fountain
water is not good enough for the kids
you know I'm drinking [__] alkaline
water what is alkaline water
you know that at erwan there is a
bottled water that costs thirty dollars
it's like 24 ounces or something like
that and it's Gotta you know it's like
this is your Wellness Elixir or
something I don't know what they do to
this water I hope it's something [__]
extraordinary but it's blessed by
Shaolin Monks but it's almost like
that's the Allure right right like we
have to buy the 30 water yeah that's
where we're at right now yeah that's
what that's that's that's it you know
that's what I wanted forget AI forget
you know everything else it's uh that's
where we're at so I think that's the
canary in the coal mine we're gonna get
back into that in in a second but I
wanted to also tell you a story a
helicopter was talking to me the other
day did you see my post when this was
happening were you crawling around on
the carpet looking for small little
white particles to smoke or stick up
your nose no with the blinds shut well
that doesn't yeah this is like I've
heard this before it generally is in a
in the closed rooms of the secret
society yes after four days of no sleep
and lots of stuff exactly exactly so
that's why you know though from those
stories it's never a good thing when the
helicopters start talking to you yeah
never awesome so I'm taking Good Fellows
right now right exactly you're like
looking for helicopters so where I swim
sometimes Will Rogers
they're they do Maneuvers like sometimes
it's LAPD sometimes it's Coast Guard
sometimes it's the sheriff's Chopper
that you often see it's like a
turnaround spot for for helicopters but
this time
I'm swimming doing my normal swim I get
to almost my turn around and I this LAPD
copper does does like three loops and
then all of a sudden I hear
a swimmer there are five or six sharks
20 yards out from you
and I look up at this helicopter that's
hovering and looking at me and I'm like
okay and then I don't do anything I like
I instead I like turn behind me as if I
would and I have my mask on I turn
behind me and I'm like all right what do
I do now do I swim in like this guy's
like worried about me like I don't like
it when people worry about me I just
that you know it makes me uncomfortable
and so uh then he says it again
you know the swimmer there's five or six
sharks and I say okay so I decided to do
it I'm pretty far out so are you around
like at the point
no I'm on my way so I started a little
bit further south on the coast I'm like
right at Bellair Bay Club so usually
I'll swim either to Bel Air Bay and back
to Temescal or I'll swim all the way to
the staircase of the sunset surf break
or maybe to the point and so this time
it was kind of just to Bellaire Bay and
so I swim back I'm pretty far out so I
do like a kind of diagonal swim and I'm
thinking about just going in because
it's like even though I'm the guy that
says sharks aren't scary
it's kind of weird to get a card
do you really believe that
a weird thing to do and not listen yeah
so I swim in but then I keep swimming
like as soon as it sees me swim close
enough to the wave it feels like okay
I'm fine like I feel like okay the
Sharks didn't follow me I can go and I
just swam back to my spot
um but I thought that was strange I was
hoping he was gonna drop a line or a
ladder and you were gonna grab onto it
and then he was gonna Elevate you out
and and you you you know take you to the
shore safely yeah help help yeah yeah so
that was weird that happened
well this just proves your thesis
they're always saying the sharks are
there all the time it's just now we see
them more but yeah well you you know who
my first call was after that whole thing
the Malibu artist right so I call him
and he says dude I was there the day but
I was there yesterday and I think I saw
those five five or six sharks but he
says when there are five or six that you
can see there's always five or six you
can't see but he told me they gave me
the the down low which is they're about
seven five to seven feet so six Footers
they're all uh basically they're all
just getting popped so it's popping
season for Great Whites we've always
thought it was a nursery out there and
now this confirms and he says they're
going to be around for like 18 months
but that also doesn't sound great if
there's a lot of babies around you know
doesn't that heighten the danger well
they're they're eating Rays they're not
like even eating Marine Mammon yeah but
if you get anywhere near any of the pups
doesn't that alert it's not the same
once they're out they're out it's not
the same yeah [__] them once they're
born
it's one of those drugs it's a drop and
run okay
all right yeah
um cool man well that's a that's those
are two good stories yes that's where I
start yeah you know there's been a
there's been a turn journalistically has
there not there's been yeah yeah yeah
then the New York Times sports uh shut
down its sport the New York Times has
shut down at sports desk so New York
Times sports as it were I guess it's not
going to exist here in the next several
weeks no one saw that coming did they
nobody's pretty crazy nobody saw it
coming because literally the people that
worked at the sports desk weren't told
until the story broke and so everyone we
all found out at the same time I mean
I'm not even putting myself because I
don't work full time for them so like I
found out when the general public found
out but so did the people that were
Staffing Staffing the sports desk and I
think there's an explanation for that
that I'm not privy to but I would
imagine it's like you don't want rumor
and all that's getting around it's
better to be out front and you know
whatever it happens there's lots of
there's there's no nice way to do
something like that so to me it's like
it's just the way they chose and that's
the way it is but it did you know I I
was saddened by it and Beyond personal
opportunity I was saddened by it because
it was such a big deal to start writing
for the New York Times sports you know
it all started for me in vertical blue
2013 my first assignment for them Nick
movoli dies
and basically like that assignment
changed everything about my career and
my life really because it led to one
breath which led to meeting you which
also led to reconnecting with my wife
April and so then there's Zuma and like
the Goggins thing and can't hurt me
wouldn't exist without one breath
without going to to that thing so the
New York Times sports is so now like
Beyond just being proud to be able to
work with some amazing editors great
photographers
um good people and and great at what
they do
um you know and to tell the story of
these athletes and free divers Open
Water swimmers Mountaineers big wave
Surfers
um triathletes you know thanks to you
and like I was I predicted in the New
York Times sports that Christian
blumenfelt would win the Tokyo goal and
then also the Iron Man yeah you know so
like the fact that we predicted that
like that's a a culmination of so many
things in the New York Times that's
because
um because of that first assign I meant
and so it was like it's really it's been
important to me so I'm bummed by it you
know John Branch I was able to work with
him on my first A1 story for the New
York Times and and he was he's been uh
on Twitter talking about like uh his
feelings about it
um I think I'll do like something on
threads or or Twitter or X whatever the
[__] it's called now
um I'll do like a um a retrospective and
kind of unpack some of the stories
because you know it's over 30 like 35
stories now I've done for them over the
years
um and I hope to stay and you know I've
got other editors there so hopefully
I'll be able to work with the times
again it's sad first endurance and
adventure sports because really uh
Washington Post does some of that but
the New York Times I think with outside
magazine were like the top for those
kinds of sure I mean they really
invested in those longer stories and
then the art direction that they kind of
Infuse them with to create these
experiences with video and imagery like
like you know it was really compelling
like the stuff that you did with Colin
O'Brien when he was going across
Antarctica I mean nobody else does that
no and so that's gone gone which sucks
it's not about daily box scores as much
as it is the more journalistic kind of
stories that are human interest as much
as they are sports I mean they kind of
transcend the sports page so I was
wondering whether those kinds of stories
could still find a home at the New York
Times just not under the sports page
because they are as much
sort of you know life and style stories
as they are sports stories it's a very
good question I don't know exactly the
answer that yet because you're right
like the idea was this Sports desk isn't
I guess
doing the job financially and we bought
the Athletics the athletic is taking
over all of that they bought the
athletic for 500 plus million dollars
and then
um as soon as they bought it I was
worried already for the sports my
friends of the sports desk because I
didn't know how that would all work but
then it seemed to be going along as
normal and then obviously one day it
isn't and um I'm not privy to the
decisions like I'm not one of those
writers that goes on Twitter and yells
about my my people who I work for it's
like this I'll never be that guy so like
if you don't have the information it's
impossible for me to be critical about
these decisions to me it's a decision
that I think is a choice and it if it
works out or not they could always
choose to go back like I was I was
writing for Playboy pretty regularly
when they decided not to do nudes
anymore and I knew one thing
that their last move was we're doing
nudes again
so yeah
I think that's a pretty predictable move
right so they could like it's if if I
don't even know the math but I'd imagine
if you want to start up a sports desk
you could do it again pretty easily so
like this isn't necessarily the end
um but you're right like to me New York
Times sports was never about although
they've had great basketball writers had
great baseball writers have they have a
great a great soccer writer Rory Smith
right now he's fantastic
um and they've got had great tennis
people but you're right the sports
section itself was kind of an expanded
view of the Sports World which you don't
get on the ESPN right you're not you're
not reading a story about free diving
and looking at these amazing photos of
these people because you're a sports nut
right it really is a curiosity that's
born as much from just trying to
understand something you've never seen
before right right and so I think we'll
see I mean I they say like the sports
business stories are now going to be
folded in under business so I hope so I
hope the adventure stuff can find a way
at home under travel maybe or under like
this just the global desk I mean I don't
know we'll see I'm gonna find I'm going
to try to find you yeah and what happens
to a friend of the Pod Matt futterman
he's you know he's cranking away he's
he's still fire the sports desk still
seems to be functioning right now they
say this transition is going to be over
at some point this month or next month
they say or they've said this is public
stuff so no one's telling me anything
privately but it sounds like by the Fall
whatever the new thing is going to be
locked in place for you as a consumer
it's still going to say Sports on your
New York Times app is just going to be
done by the Athletics team yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then I guess
more broadly what is that auger in terms
of the media landscape like oh the New
York Times Like got rid of their Sports
and no big deal well they had the
Athletics so it really is just a
shuffling of the deck I suppose it is
but I don't think the athletic covers
these is it sort of like
um you know Elon comes in buys Twitter
like you know fires like you know a
massive number number of the employees
and somehow the app still seems to work
right and you can argue about how well
it works but uh then all the other CEOs
are like huh you know maybe maybe I can
cut my Workforce back as well like is
there some of that happening will they
solve that announcement with other
journalistic outlets they say Bezos is
taking an increased interest in the
Washington Post so that's never good
when when the money guys start showing
up right right like I don't know I mean
um
journalism has been fraught for a long
time this is a reminder that anything
can happen at any time no one would have
ever predicted this I don't think even
after they bought the athletic it seemed
to be a parallel business and it didn't
seem to be part of the same thing I
guess it might take my concern is like
you've already said the endurance in
adventure sports like do will they have
a home because the athletic is more kind
of an ESPN similar than ESPN their focus
is on these very mainstream Sports And
so there's not really a lot of coverage
there's not a receptivity to the kind of
stories that you do it doesn't seem to
be and I wouldn't even know who like the
other thing about this business is you
have to know who to approach right like
I don't know anyone in the Athletics
who's your guy I don't have an inside
guy but here's the thing yeah uh these
stories uh find a way right like free
diving will not die as a matter of fact
it found its way all the way to Netflix
it did and uh your star is on the rise
my friend because you made your Netflix
debut in a in a Smash Hit it's hey you
know what the deepest breath it's it's
cranking it's been top 10 on Netflix for
a couple of weeks yeah pretty exciting
yes it's been it's been great I knew
that I knew that that the film had
potential
when they first were putting it together
lorem again the director and her
producers at Venture Land approached me
early on
um because they were looking at doing a
story on Stephen Keenan and Alessia
zakini
um Alessia is uh a world record holder
Italian free diver Stephen Keenan is the
greatest safety diver in the history of
the sport with some amazing rescues
under his belt and and uh has an Irish
National Record holder as well so their
their story I'd reported on kind of the
Crux of what happens I'm not going to
spoil it in the deepest breath for
outside once before and then obviously
they'd read one breath and so they
approached me early on and I was very
encouraging saying I've always loved
this story I think there's a great
potential for the story I'm happy you're
doing it it was an Irish director doing
it which I also liked
um and so but then you know they asked
me to come to Vertical blue but it just
didn't work out like I I think it was it
was vertical blue right after the
pandemic it was like hard hard for me to
get there and so I I figured I wasn't
going to be in it then they came kind of
towards the end of production and
they've they they we did a shoot out
here in LA but the important question is
how much do you think roll-on has
contributed to the success of the
deepest breath because definitely so
despite my best efforts to steer the
conversation away from freediving week
in and week out this is the sport that
refuses to go away it really is you just
find a reason to bring it back and now
it's on Netflix and you know you are
you're playing a role in the Ascension
of this Sport and how many how many
skolnik heads you know we're logging
into Netflix and upping up the algorithm
there to push that into the top down
there's no question the Rich Roll
skolnik heads have had something to do
with this I've been hearing from them
um and you know what like it's cool to
see I think that the success of the the
movie is really that people in the
mainstream are seeing the sport like you
said the images and the video you can
get especially now is amazing and
vertical blue they started pioneering
this this camera that it's an uh you
know remote operated vehicle that go
dive eye and it goes all the way down
the line and so the fact that that
exists it didn't exist when when I was
doing one breath we only were using
Sonar and so you could see it if you
Dove down for the first you know 20
meters and then come back up but you
weren't seeing what's happening the fact
that you have that and you can see this
footage it's you really only like dive
nerds like me that were watching that
stuff on YouTube it's out there but now
people are seeing it and the way the
sound design and the film is so great it
really like wraps you up cinematically
yeah it's quite beautiful I wouldn't be
surprised if they got some Oscar Oscar
Noms yeah that would be cool right yeah
Oscar nominated School Nick Hearing in
an Oscar
so here I'm looking at the outline and
you've got like eight more points about
free diving in here with a bunch of
names Eastern Bloc and Russian Ukrainian
names in here we're not we're not going
to do this Adam we're not we spent
enough time on freediving okay
yeah
like we don't need to get into buy fins
and you know yeah whatever it's cool
check out the show on Netflix
and the story end of story right let's
put a button on this okay
um oh can I just say one thing Alexi
molchanov two more World Records what
133 meters bro one breath 133 meters
cool
that is awesome actually that's
something all right I gave you that one
all right maybe I'll knock it out it's
not good yeah get it out later anything
else you want to share I'm gonna ask
Chris Evans what he thinks about it
trust me I'm sure he's got an opinion or
two
um all right yeah what about you man
what's been going on I know you've been
working I'm sitting here waiting for you
to ask about me Adam so I could share
do you sometimes when you're sitting
across from someone just completely tune
out and just plan what you're gonna say
next
I do do that or I have done that but
that's also when I start doing that I
know that things are going off the rails
this is not going to be a good podcast
because if I can't pay attention yeah
that's not you that's not you
um what's good man Life Is Life is good
I'm dealing with a little in-between
here right now you know I had short hair
I'm decided to grow it out a little bit
yeah now I don't know what to do with it
and just looks bad no matter what I do I
think this is true growing the beard out
getting a little more here suits
when I first saw you I said how great
you looked I like this in between well
there's a power dynamic between us
though right I have to take that with a
great assault
you don't trust my opinion
since we last did this again end of May
yeah I mean where it even began a lot of
travel a lot of family time yeah I think
the last time we did it was right before
I went to Australia yeah with Australia
did a bunch did a couple podcasts give
speech had some trips with the kids uh
recorded a ton of podcasts
um we're finalizing
voicing change volume three oh exciting
more on that soon but that book is on
the horizon uh we have um
Sir Patrick Stewart coming in later
really yeah that's great that's an
exciting guest for sure yeah that'll be
fun
um we passed a million YouTube
subscribers so thank you everyone who
who has uh subscribed to that channel
um that's pretty exciting one million is
pretty good yeah it's pretty cool it's
for real I mean not that
you know I posted about this on
Instagram I I try not to get caught up
in in that kind of stuff because it just
you know it it tweaks with how you think
about what you want to do on the show
when you start thinking about numbers
and audience and stuff like that but
um I think it's important to to
celebrate those
um landmarks for sure also for all of
our co-workers here and and and for the
fans and the people that have been on
this journey with us it's it's it's it's
a wild thing man that's a lot of people
it's hard your brain can't really wrap
itself around that well the the the
YouTube channel kind of you only started
intensively looking at YouTube not too
long ago actually in terms of the life
of the show right a handful of years ago
yeah yeah yeah yeah and we're still
learning a lot you know I I would say
the the vast majority of the audiences
Audio Only still and and we're learning
as we go with YouTube uh and I think
there's a lot of growth opportunity
there and it's exciting and I love the
fact that we do it visually and we have
the studio and you know we're executing
at such a high level in terms of
production value and trying to deliver
something interesting
um on you know on that platform so
anyway it's a it's a cool little thing
to celebrate so thank you everybody for
that super cool on the health front um
I've had a lot of progress with my lower
back I know I've shared many times about
being kind of hampered so to speak
um through this chronic lower back
injury
um and pain that I've been dealing with
for many many years but
the last person on the on the Whistle
Stop tour uh was a guy that I found up
in Sonoma County he's really been
helping me out so I've been going up
there uh like once a month I've been up
there for three visits where I stay for
a couple days this guy works on me and
I've had
um real progress I'm not out of the
woods yet but I've had more mobility and
flexibility and less pain than I've had
since probably like
2017 which was the last time that I was
truly like fit so
I'm not exactly back to training
training but I can move my body in a way
that I haven't been able to in a number
of years so I see right at the end of
the end of the at the end of the tunnel
I saw the long way to go to kind of
completely liberate myself of this issue
but
um I'm pretty optimistic for the first
time in a long time and I think I'm
going to be able to
solve this short of surgery which was my
goal to figure it out and if I needed
surgery I'm happy to have surgery but I
wanted to explore everything else prior
to that and it kind of uh lost hope and
had resigned myself to you know getting
cut open and having it dealt with that
way but I'm actually having real
progress right now so we'll see where
that leads but I'm back on the bike I
can swim I got to keep it pretty chill
uh the running stuff is at a very low
simmer at the moment but everything else
like I'm able to I just I feel like
myself again that's awesome you forget
like this is who I am and when I can't
express myself that way I don't feel
myself right but I really do feel like
myself uh in a way that I almost
forgotten and that's pretty exciting and
feels good it's exciting and did is this
a PT guy is it a like a a he's a medical
doctor he's a multi-disciplinary now
it's got it's a long story he he has a
lot of different modalities that he
works with but he has a very specific
car Chiropractic technique that is very
painful where he cracks my back in a
certain way that makes me feel like he's
going to paralyze me but has really uh
loosened things up for me wow
interesting yeah cool
um that's really it uh I don't have lots
of funny stories about water fountains
and sharks and stuff like that you know
I just come to the studio and I do my
thing
although I think about my warm open for
days in advance I I can tell it's very
scripted
a little State some no I have notes Adam
it felt a little spontaneous but yeah
maybe a little bit too thought out
beforehand but you used to I used to
come on here and just say I'm great how
are you and then I started getting
heckled remember
anyway
um life is good I'm very grateful to be
able to do this thing and uh celebrate
it with so many people so I just wanted
to recognize the audience for taking
this journey with us it's good to be
back with you
um I am headed to London in a couple
weeks which I'm very excited about I
want to share a little bit more about
what that is all about but I think this
is a good time to take a quick break and
then we'll come back and bring Chris on
beautiful awesome
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rocas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
all right are we good no we're not good
I'm not good come on Chris you look
fantastic I look at you I am you're a
star over the moon to have you sit here
and join us today I have no idea what's
going to happen we have a whole outline
I have a feeling we're not going to get
to any of it but I'm just thrilled to
sit across from you to have you in the
studio so you can share this experience
with us but also before we even get into
anything like I I honestly from the
bottom of my heart uh I I owe you such a
massive debt of gratitude I just wanted
to thank you publicly for all the
support that you have given that you
continue to give uh to the podcast to
roll on specifically and you know when I
go to London like we the popularity of
the show in the UK and in London
specifically is due entirely to your
promotion and advocacy and you know it's
just it's I I can't thank you enough for
the support that that you've given us
over the years it like really means a
lot and so it's an absolute thrill to
have you here today thank you so much
for all that
however that doesn't mean I'm not
totally opposed to my own appearance on
this program right now
I couldn't be more against what is
currently happening on roll on as a
super funny you're you're you love it
you're happy to be here I know you are I
was thrilled to be invited out to come
and watch you and and meet the whole
team who I love by the way
um but the there are a few cardinal sins
on that you commit from time to time the
the biggest cardinal sin is when you
invite a third party on to the show so I
am now committing the Cardinals but I'm
not committing it I've it's commit but I
barely commitment I don't know it's not
fair I'm forcing you so people take
responsibility people back in the UK say
he's just saying that he cut he loves be
it I I am so against his appearance
that's the first thing the second thing
is when you when you mess around with
the
original actually that's the third thing
the second thing is when you refer to
Via emails or texts to me oh it's going
to be an old school roll on right like
Roland's been around forever right in
audio entertainment in in our universe
yes this podcast has been around for
about a minute alone roll on yeah you
referred to roll on as they're not oh we
may do an old school roll on oh my God
have you been on the air for about a
second YouTube okay
get back get back in your house in the
podcast World actually time moves very
very very fast very very very okay yeah
let's go with that yeah yeah and anyway
the third thing is to mess around with
the format and that this I I you know I
love robots I know I I was you're the
roll-on number one fan I couldn't be
more special to be invited out to Los
Angeles to meet Adam and his friend Rich
that's very kind of you you are well I
want notes though I like your notes like
you you've always been a big supporter
of this version of the podcast you have
strong opinions about when we go astray
what we should do what we shouldn't do
and you're you're the [__] Legend
dude so I when you say do this don't do
that like I'm paying attention I hope to
goodness I don't say to you to do this
done to that where this this or well
you'll say this works for me this
doesn't work for me yeah I know you have
a certain wisdom you're not just the
average listener you actually uh you
know you've you've you've made quite a
name for yourself in in this
broadcasting business so of course we're
gonna listen to everything you say
everything please don't do that please
the the the number
two problem most people haven't in the
world yeah is is getting what they want
because the number one problem is that
they have is they don't know what they
want right and when you refer to well
you know the feedback has been missed
the fee they don't know what they want
people listening to this they just
reverse engineer what they think they
want because then they have the agency
over they want it in the first place
they they need what you give them and
then they interpret that as to what they
want
so you just you do you come from the
heart and you express yourself
authentically and the people will come
that's what happens yeah and the guests
will come and your team you I had the
backstory of your team and how they came
to be and how Jason came you know to
relocated here and Dan relocated here
yeah you know and they were all doing
different things at different times you
know and and Dan was a pastor right
um you know and uh he was a whole
different human being and then he
realized that he was losing his faith
and that he wasn't living to his true
nature and that's why the road of life
was bumpy and then the more you align
yourself to who you are you know Guru
Singh talks about this all the time then
the more things
start to happen because your sailing as
opposed you're sailing with the wind as
opposed to rowing against the tide and
suddenly life gets a bit more fluid and
fluent and it's almost and that's how it
feels yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's
a great way of putting it yeah well I
mean I think you you share that from a
place of wisdom and like learned lived
experience because you're somebody not
you know as a broadcaster you've been
doing this for a long time but you've
had massive success you've you know kind
of come to terms with the emptiness of
certain aspects of that and the way that
you live your life now is very different
from how you were living it not that
long ago well it's 67 days ago I have my
last drink yeah you've even stopped me
drinking I know that's fantastic 67 days
yeah wow yeah yeah I'm my wife
and we've we stopped on a on a Saturday
morning nobody stopped stringing on a
Saturday morning no you leave it to them
yeah Sunday lunch right we had quite a
big fun it's Sunday lunch yeah Sunday
lunch then you quit yeah or Saturday
night yeah but we did that thing where I
told you I went to him what was
happening well nothing really I mean you
know we just
you know why why does anybody drink why
does anybody consume anything from the
outside in you know
um to pursue pleasure
um for various reasons very various
differing times in one's life you know
and I told you I went to this meeting on
the beach the other day and this guy
described it beautifully he said you
know for for a long time when I was
drinking and I was using and I was
abusing uh things and substances and
people and having a great time but
without little substance although all
the substances then you have all the fun
you can have all the fun and then you
have a lot of the fun and you have a few
problems and then you have more problems
and a bit of fun and then you just have
the problems that's one way of
describing it another way of describing
it and there are thousands as you know
um would be you used to have a drink to
take the edge off yeah well I found now
um that we were having a drink and it
was taking the Shine off because our
lives were shiny um and I suddenly felt
like
whatever was working before wasn't
working now and the next day there was
less of the good stuff
and there was more of the good stuff to
begin with it's more palpable
and why would you rough up your own
Diamond as it were yeah and that we I
got up 60 whatever 67 days ago and I
said to Tasha I don't know this anymore
I should one with you and then we just
stopped that's beautiful
um so it's just athletic greens from
here on out hey G1 baby yeah around at
my place yeah come on I love that but
even Beyond getting athletic greens now
yeah yeah it's anything yeah mainlining
it yeah
kids in it and smelling them yes yeah
well I had mentioned uh before the break
that I'm going to London in a couple
weeks and uh a bit you know the main
reason for that is I'm gonna be
participating in your upcoming car Fest
event so I wanted you to share a little
bit about what that event is about but
just the fact that it's called carfest
is interesting because it it it it
illustrates a little bit of your Arc
because it's not you used to be like a
guy with a huge car collection right
like you're you had like a Jay Leno
situation going on but you've you don't
live that way you you you you're on like
you're on vacation every thing you
packed is light Walk In Style and that
backpack over there you've really
stripped down your life and gotten more
clear on what's important what's not
important so as a lead into talking
about carfest like to share a little bit
about that Journey because I think
people think well that's fine for him to
say but like I I need that success and
that success is going to fill that hole
for me and you found otherwise yeah this
is taking it's a proper show now I know
I can't help it I can't help it I told
you the outside people people want to
roll on back we'll get back 25 minutes
there are there's a bunch of stuff I
need to talk about but go ahead really I
want to contextualize that jeez
just came here to one yeah I promise I
came into one now you have to open your
heart and soul [__] I know a cheering
would be good coffee started off as um I
always wanted to do a family Festival
um and so but I I knew that calling it
family fest or whatever would be
something that
um would be a worthwhile a worthy thing
to do but it wouldn't get people through
the door and and then one day I was
going uh to this um and now I wasn't
going anywhere it was January it was the
third week in January it was it was
raining even more than it usually does
in in Britain and it was cold and it was
miserable and there was this car show an
indoor car show in January where nobody
had any money and there was a 25 mile
tailback on the motorway the highway
because people were going to tune up to
go to this coach I think people got a
car show third week in January indoors
let's just let's call our family
Festival a car show and so so we did and
it worked and so we got families to come
to the car it was a car Festival but
there were bands on as well and that was
21 festivals ago and since then it's
transmogrified but I was I did I was
into cars at the time sorry but I evaded
your question and I didn't want to
nobody I mean it's a great thing to
bring kids to so it's like like Zuma if
it was a if it was like a construction
vehicle show yeah we'd be there yeah
well you know it's fun it's fun isn't it
you know it gets people through the gate
but then you bring everything else in
the back door it's a bit like your
podcast you know it's a bit like the
fact that it's an easy conversation uh
it's you you have a lovely articulation
uh you know and a great point of view on
life you've you've you've lived and died
once and we only get you get two lives
not one the second of which only begins
when you realize the first one is over
and that's the Phoenix from the flames
and that's the great inspiration for all
of us today's a new day every day above
ground or this kind of stuff
um and but it's those you bring these
stories in via the back door is that to
sort of uh strategic or is is it a soft
launch or is it does it make it easy for
people to get in or whatever
um but that's how our Festival started
as a car festival and now it's still
called car Fest we thought about
changing the name
um but it still has great cars and it
now has 21 bands and it has loads of
people and you'll come to speak at it
and it's [__] great yeah it's cool
it's great and you you get like 80 100
000 people coming through right yeah and
all the money goes to charity every
single penny goes yeah amazing
incredible so I know uh the happy para
guys I think are coming yeah Russell
Brands coming Laura's coming so I don't
know where you're gonna throw me in here
or there but I'm I'm willing and ready
whatever you want me to do many hay
bales that you can sit on and you can
you can uh you can errate and you can uh
hypnotize and you can do whatever the
hell you like Rich Roll cool Rich are
you still into hypnotism
I had the hypnotism guy on the show he
told me I was not that hypnotizable
though they do this test where you look
up or whatever with your eyeballs and
they can tell how receptive you are to
hypnosis that's good you know that if
you listen to my podcast you would know
this I knew that yeah his dad taught him
but Ed Hawkins Ed Hawkins has written a
book called The Man of Magic the men on
magic carpets I don't know this book do
you know this no oh it's so good so so
for the US the US military employed
hypnosis Mass hypnosis you know this
yeah that was like the men staring at
Goats project yeah same kind of thing
and
um from the same seed of the U.S
military and they um they they they
brought in some famous uh sort of uh
psychics from around the world and they
didn't care if these these guys were
frauds or not because just in case they
weren't because in war anything is worth
it to depending on your point of view
right and they brought in all these
people and they they said there is
something here there is something here
and what they did was
um the book is all about the fact that
these super hypnotizers with these
superpowers of hypnosis who were
employed in the military who were
soldiers but just happened to have them
and they would deployed Behind Enemy
Lines to disrupt the vibration of the of
the of the the the enemy they then at
the end of any particular conflict were
not unemployable but unemployed so
sports teams in the US started to employ
them to to place them in opposing fans
areas of the stadium disrupt the
vibration of the crowd that would then
influence the the players on the pitch
and [__] up their whole gameplay wow and
it's a real thing this guy called Ed
Hawkins and you love him he's like that
he's like the J Robert Robert
Oppenheimer of hypnosis yes yeah but
also they say the Manhattan Project of
hypnosis yeah but they say that Cinema
and and radio shows and podcasts and
literature is all a form of mass
hypnosis anyway oh there's no question
for sure yeah there's no question yeah
yeah
speaking of massive gnosis I think
there's people running around La uh
still dressed in pink from Barbie now
they're just filing into Sofi for the uh
for Sailors yeah I mean there is
something about social media and the
group think kind of Paradigm not for
good and for bad that is there's a
hypnosis of the phone right yeah for
sure yeah yeah that's there we're
conducting a massive experiment on we
just don't know at the moment yes we
kind of know it but we're all signing up
for it anyway some people know yeah
um well I'm excited to go to carfest uh
what's the website for it and the dates
because it's not sold out if anyone's
listening carfest.org we can always fit
more people in come and join us even if
you can't stand me just come anyway
there's a hundred thousand people there
yeah you don't have to rub elbows with
Chris absolutely you don't need to do
that but lots of great people there for
all the right reasons and it's just
somebody once said one of the best
things uh two well two different people
said it's two different things one said
one of the best things you can do is buy
a ticket
to help someone you'll never meet and
that's what you'll be doing by coming to
this Festival
and somebody else said another great
thing that human being can do is give
other human beings a reason to get
together and this fulfills both those
yeah that's beautiful and you'll have a
great time yeah cool August 24 to 26
August 25 to 20 25. we'll take you
whenever you get there
if you want to leave early to go to
Switzerland that's coming up
yeah exactly so it's so after after I do
carfest I'm actually
um headed to Zurich which I'm very
excited about uh the reason for that is
to visit the headquarters of on on
running the running shoe brand you see
them wearing the on shoes uh because we
have just I'm taking this opportunity to
announce this uh incredible huge new
partnership that we've formed with on so
I'm gonna go to the headquarters and
visit with the folks there
um which is is you know honestly like
I'm happy I'm going to car Fest but
really I'm going to Zurich it's okay
yeah I'm fine I'm happy today these guys
will take whatever which role we can get
and uh you know this is a relationship
um that uh we've been cultivating
cultivating for some time it's a
Cornerstone partnership and not just the
business of this podcast but I think
it's representative of of
um the value set behind the you know the
why behind everything that we do
um and let's face it this is a
commercial Enterprise the show doesn't
exist without sponsors but I think you
know it's interesting to kind of address
this from a broader perspective to kind
of understand the decisions that get
made about who to align with in this
commercial Enterprise if you listen to
podcasts you're used to hearing ads
um for a lot of shows it's just you know
something that people do like they just
do ads for you know whoever will buy ad
space on their show and the longer that
we've been doing this
The more I've come to realize that I
don't really want to participate in that
game obviously you know we need sponsors
to do what it is that we do but I'm not
interested in just aligning with whoever
I'd much rather have and this is the
consensus with everyone who works here
to have fewer partners
but more in-depth relationships with
those Partners so as you might imagine
uh we're on the receiving end of a lot
of inquiries people who want to
advertise on the show and I would say we
say no to you know 95 out of 100 of
those requests we reject them because
there isn't there's just something
that's not properly aligned but every
once in a while somebody shows up where
the values align almost perfectly with
what we're doing and I would say
wholeheartedly that that's the case with
on this is a company that is really
headed in the right direction they truly
are all about trying to get people out
and move in the most kind of
community-based way they are an
organization that has big designs on the
future of products and sustainability
and circularity and the materials that
they're working with and they're just a
high Vibe group of people who you know I
just think we can do amazing things
together so I'm really excited to launch
into that can I ask you a question about
like the inter-workings of uh how you
choose like how you're you say you're
hyper selective and obviously the bigger
the show has gotten the more corporate
opportunities are coming to you right
which I would imagine are pretty
lucrative so how do you go about what's
the what's the way that you kind of
these opportunities come to you and how
you make the selection in terms of on
like how did that come about
so
it comes in various ways I mean you get
incoming emails all the time and we have
uh uh a management team that kind of
vets all this stuff as a kind of first
line of defense so it all has to pass
through their kind of Machinery before
it even gets to me a lot of the incoming
but often it's I'm looking at companies
that are out there and going after the
ones that you know I think would be good
partners rather than just reacting to
what's out there being intentional like
here are the people that I would like to
align with and sometimes you know that
takes a long time to cultivate those
relationships and get to a place where
it makes sense on both sides because
it's a partnership it isn't just oh
you're an Advertiser it's like hey I
realize like I'm you know I need to
enter this relationship from a
perspective of how I'm delivering value
for the brand it's not just how much
money can I get from them so I'll do a
60-second read like yes you hear the ad
but what's really going on is this
exchange of values and how we can
mutually benefit at each other through
this exchange and so very few companies
make it through that
um or there are some cool companies that
are doing really interesting things but
maybe there's something off about them
let's revisit that a little bit later
it's a you know it's kind of like a
dynamic organism that's always shifting
and evolving right no I mean it's good
that you to hear that because I know
personally my parents will buy anything
you suggest so the fact that there is a
nice like you're you're really vetting
it and it's really not just something
that kind of topically aligns but
there's a deeper alignment I think is
cool no they're conscious decisions
they're value-based decisions but people
know I know when I'm listening I hope
everybody knows no but everybody knows
we all know that's that's why that show
is called The X Factor everybody knows
sometimes we don't even know we know
but
we know I definitely don't know I know I
know yeah I know Chris how's this going
for you so far
I'm trying to pretend that it's okay
this is not okay even when we got a
little bit meaningful before that's
still what none of this is okay I just
came to Los Angeles for 28 days to
pretend to live here
so that's what I do once yeah I come and
pretend that I live here that I toy with
what kind of jobs what kind of job could
I get if I came here and I top of the
list so far I'll do anything here it's
not not behind the mic I would come and
work on the team I would I'd come here
and run Russell Brands company I would
do that but his company's in the UK so
he would have to move his company he
lives next door to you basically yeah
but so he would have to move everybody
ahead just so I could come and get a job
here but then I was thinking about I
could be a pill guy I'd be very happy
being a pill could happen in the Hills
up Doheny up in the bed what about one
of those guys that like spins the arrow
at the Cardinal ships no not gonna spin
the area no not nowadays I'm 57. the the
digits went well you don't have the
dexterity yeah but of the pool I could
do the pool it's very meditative it's
right into the pool I could walk dogs
nice big GMC van with the sliding door
there's a lot about the vehicle for me
because I I really want to get a rivian
yeah but you can't get a review on on
planet Earth at the moment I don't think
you can get the rivian on the dog walker
because you can be a superstar pool guy
or a dog walker in Los Angeles
Rockstar
we have the
world's greatest it's it's an insult to
call him a dog walker so we have two big
dogs and there's a guy in our area
called Aki and he has developed quite
the reputation for being the guy to like
take care of your dogs like during the
day if you're off at work and he shows
up with a trailer and he'll come into
our house and get our dogs at like 5 30
6 in the morning and those dogs will
join a pack of about 40 dogs and he
takes these dogs
out on trails that he he makes his own
Trails he goes up in the Santa Monica
Monica Mountains and like bushwhacks his
own trails and he rides a horse bareback
and he has all these dogs without
leashes no leashes and he is in total
command of these dogs and they have a
blast just running all over going in
creeks and all this kind of stuff and
this guy is an absolute wizard like he
thinks like a dog he understands dogs
these dogs respect him he's a very
handsome dog and he's a very handsome
guy he's legitimately he makes his own
dog food he delivers it to your house
like this guy is a superstar right
I wonder how much he gets paid no that's
my ribbian sheep
I think he's doing fine
um but my point being like you know only
in La would this guy be able to like do
his thing and you know we got a snake
wrangler guy like that who's the snake
fool he dresses up like Crocodile Dundee
and he shows up at your house so if
you're you know in certain months of the
year like the like rattlesnakes are a
thing like it's a real thing they're all
over the place so if you're gonna have
like a if you're gonna have like a
dinner party outside or you're gonna
have a wedding at your house or a
birthday party you kind of want to have
this guy come over and do a quick check
before a bunch of little kids are going
to be running around and invariably no
matter what he finds a rattlesnake so
I'm convinced that he's releasing them
he brings them with them he has one
rattlesnake but if he does find that
then he will if I'm being charitable you
know he he does find them he'll relocate
them and then he does all this to the
next education like he's got binders and
he does stuff with kids where he
explains to them what happens if you get
bit by a snake location to the next
party
um
exactly it's circular it's a circular
economy yeah yeah
it really is
yeah I've got for you yeah but you're
like listen you're locked in in London
with Virgin right you're not going
anywhere anytime soon no but I think one
day we'll end up here I love it I used
to live here yeah what is it about LA
because I'm I'm falling in love with
London
we could do half a year half a year yeah
it'd be fine yeah uh L.A some people say
they don't like you know America which
isn't on statements and people say they
don't like Los Angeles which I think is
an unstatement It's like because there's
some part of everybody and everywhere
that is likable you know and what is
what is good and what is bad you know it
is only thinking that makes it so Adam
he said that
uh you just said it Shakespeare said it
before me but somebody else did
beforehand but that's okay because
that's the latest to say it uh I heard
of him yeah yeah for me just it just
lights me up in fact for a long time I
didn't come here on purpose and I didn't
come here on purpose because I knew it
would light me up so much it would
influence my thinking and my style and
all this kind of stuff I'm like because
I'd witnessed other people that had been
over here because you know my wife loves
New York she likes LA but she she really
loves New York and likes La I like it
New York and I love La you know sources
of course I think but I witnessed a lot
of people that came over here then came
back to the UK and were two sort of
Americana by it or or Los Angeles so I
left it a while until I was I think it
was 27 26 I came here with work first of
all
um to do a TV thing and um 27 years old
came out fell in love with the whole
thing created process people mean it
they get it done you've got to be any
good to be in the room you know that
great phrase you know if you're the
smartest guy in the room you're in the
wrong room yeah really really happens
over here it may happen for one meeting
if it happens for two you gotta have a
serious word with yourself
um I loved all the pre-breakfast stuff
if you know we had a few meetings with
but we were we were hot at the time for
a TV show and
um Bernie brustin was my manager you
know Benny I didn't know him personally
but he was my manager him and Brad Brad
gray right right and um came over here
and you know all the things that
happened before 10. you know breakfast
meeting here breakfast meeting there
it's exciting stuff it's juicy you know
people can say it's BS I didn't find it
BS at all I find people who call out
other people who are doing things
uh it's a bit of a lot of projection
yeah you know because they're not doing
anything well it's easy to make fun of
Los Angeles and you know there's a lot
of problems here and traffic but I think
most people's experiences they fly into
LAX which is the most the world's most
embarrassing airport it's just [__]
horrible right and then they're on the
405. they're stuck in traffic yeah it's
you know crowded it takes forever to get
from one side of town to the next so
it's an easy low-hanging Target also
it's it's the problem with LA as someone
who's a visitor who doesn't have a
connection here is that it's kind of
obtuse it's hard to wrap your head
around it's like this massive kind of
concept there's no local Dragon right
anything that's going and especially for
years when downtown was like a no-go
Zone like there was just nothing
culturally interesting happening down
there really in terms of like uh
entertainment or or restaurants there
was some interesting kind of neat niches
but there wasn't really like it wasn't
really The Happening spot now there's a
lot more happening at all the different
hoods but it's just hard to kind of know
where to go when and what's happening
because it's just so big and there's
like so you've carved out Venice right
Venice is your spot yeah yeah and so
you'll notice that you probably won't
leave Venice too much right no I mean
not at all because we don't have a car
over here so right so that's a good way
to carve out a time in LA is to pick
your spot yeah and just and you know get
get into the to the detail of it yeah
yeah and live pretend you know we're
very fortunate I get four weeks holiday
in the summer so we can we rent a house
we don't stay in a hotel so we can
pretend to live here it's I'm sure it's
nothing at all like living here even
from having lived here in the past but
that was up in the hills but um but I I
love it I think the freedom of the the
the the the different the difference in
the demographic of the people you can
see if you take a run on the boardwalk
at 6am between 6 a.m and 5 a.m in five
minutes you've seen so many different
kinds of people different genres
different events different uh status or
whatever that means you know
um but
you know the only thing to fear is is
fear itself I think you know they they
say but isn't that isn't that a police
helicopter hovering over your house at
500 feet for most of the day I say yeah
how much would that cost security wise
he's got that that's a that's Megan
Harry don't have that no and they're
paying through the nose this is for free
it's the safest neighborhood in the
world
she doesn't mean yeah it's for free
um you said something before we started
about parito's law of living parrito
perito's principle yeah
talk to us about that because you were
saying that there's some some something
on the like your experience of running
on the boardwalk surfing there and then
like seeing la come to life in the
morning kind of made you think of it
well pretest principle is the age 20
rule basically there's different
interpretations of it but 80 20. so for
example in business in life friends
whatever energy so so 20 of your
activity gives you 80 of of the the sort
of end product of whatever that may be
twenty percent of your customers
sometimes give you 80 of your Revenue
eighty percent of your customers only
give you 20 of your revenue and often 80
or even 100 of your problems so it's
about identifying the most efficient and
energy you can put into various Lanes of
your life that will give you the
greatest
um the greatest sort of uh payback yeah
um and you can do it with people and you
can do it with energy and like for
example in the morning you get up well
begun it's half done you know so so you
you win
sit you wake up
um somebody said the other day I woke up
you know and when I was living this life
which wasn't great I had a I woke up and
my my I just been dumped and I didn't
like my boss and I didn't have any money
and I was about to get thrown out of my
apartment well actually no that that's
not what happened what happened was I
woke up and opened my eyes that's
actually what happened but the story
goes so that's the opposite of where
we're going to soft done but you get up
in the morning you do something great
you set your intention for 10 minutes so
you have a bit of a moment of gratitude
that's already great you've already
flicked the right switch not the wrong
switch and then you go for a run or you
do some stretching or you drink some
water that's even better and so so if
you front load the day or front load
your business or front load your
friendship or your front load your body
with something that's great for you then
the rest of the day it's a bit like
living in LA and having all those
pre-breakfast meetings the rest of they
can be Administration bureaucracy to
sort of to sort of varnish this the
Beautiful thing that you've just created
and often you find that we are expending
a lot of uh 100 of our energy on
zero outcome and so previous principle
is all about that it's 80 20 or it can
be 99.1 and when you're exercising and
or you're gardening if probably if you
see exercising and training is different
so if you exercise you're exercising if
you're training your training via
exercise for an event which is useful
isn't it because it gives you a sort of
something's aim for but if you are
looking for example for
um
the blue zones Gambino so the one of the
number one uh activities in the Blue
zone is to Garden because Garden is
movement
um but it's also Community but sometimes
when you exercise all you have left from
the moment you finish exercising all
that happens sometimes is guilt guilt by
destroying beginning to destroy the hour
of exercise that you've just achieved by
consuming or by sitting down or by doing
something else whereas if you Garden you
get the exercise and after the exercise
you also have a garden so that's like
that's like 99 what right because you're
it's it's giving you everything and
costing you nothing other than your
attention and your energy and your time
and you know what do they say energy
goes where attention energy Grows Where
attention goes and the better the
attention that you focus on it the more
it gives birth to more of that stuff
that magnet autism of stuff that makes
you want to not even want to be a better
person when you automatically start to
be better and when you cross that
threshold of where things that were good
for you became an effort and you didn't
look forward to doing them even though
you wanted the the the outcome
that moment when you miss a workout and
you feel like you did
before wanting not wanting to do a
workout you have the regret have not
have it worked out you start to feel off
when you don't work out sure and you
cross the threshold you go
it's the other side of the fence that
people talk about I'm just going to get
you you want to take the seat let's go
get a drink you're right because I
shouldn't have three people so I'm gonna
leave and you can sit here can I
actually go and watch the rest of it
yeah I would love to do the homework
yeah well we're going to take a quick ad
Break
um anyway can I just apologize to all
fellow Roland fans this was a mistake
look at that he just drops like a wisdom
bomb and then declares that it was a
mistake
I love it man how great to have the
number one roll lines roll-on fans
sitting with us unbelievable and then
leaving us like like like with like a
puff of smoke
thank you Chris if we were going to have
a third wheel he is the guy to do it oh
God yeah I think yes we're leaving
Chris's chair open in the event that he
might want to return we'll see it's up
to him can I just switch seats sometimes
tell Jason so he can make sure the mic
is hot no you cannot
um there's a lot of rules around here
lately well yeah you
for like pareto's principle burrito
burrito that's your new rule right are
you well uh it's it's it's now called
the Chris Evans rule for living there
you go yeah that was a mic drop moment
um for the old school roll on hardcores
we're gonna do a little bit of news
share a little streaming wrecks I guess
right we're gonna keep it Breezy but we
can't uh not talk about Sean Conway
breaking the iron Cowboys record for
most consecutive Iron Man's this guy
clocked off
105. Chris was just saying during the
break that he he came out twice came on
twice on uh on Chris's show right before
he broke the record or right after
the day of and then he kept going what
was interesting is obviously he wanted
to do 102 because then he would Eclipse
James's record but then after that it
was like a day by day thing he would
wake up and decide whether he was going
to keep going yeah and he kept going and
then on the 105th day he was sort of
like okay I'm pretty sure this is the
last time I'm gonna do it but he knocked
off 105 of them this is a really
interesting guy he's from Zimbabwe he
lives in Wales he started this thing off
on April 10th so again in Iron Man every
single day not missing a not missing no
days off 105 total
um
also interesting is that after James set
his record back in June of 2022 Sean
started uh he that was his first attempt
at doing this he was going to try to
break James I think he got like six in
and he got injured and he had to call it
off and it was like maybe not so easy
right like we talked about that but you
know to his credit he basically healed
up and got right back on the horse and
went after it again and he seemed to do
it like these guys I haven't met Sean I
mean Chris knows Sean and I guess Sean's
going to be a car Fest right which is
cool I'm going to try to do a podcast
with him in London but just based on
what I have intuited from following him
on Instagram he seems pretty chill like
he doesn't he doesn't have that same
kind of iron Cowboy Super intensity he's
got little kids seems like a super nice
guy he kind of got fit in the process of
doing it he has a before and after
picture on Instagram right now where His
Image the image of him without a shirt
on before he began he just looked like a
dude right he's all ripped up at the end
of it but uh I don't know there seems to
be uh a more laid back kind of attitude
about doing this team did he have a team
like the same idea like a Peloton for
the cycle for the bike and and uh it
seemed like he did yeah yeah I mean
probably it didn't it didn't gain
momentum like James where there were
like thousands of people at the end but
I think he had a core crew of people who
were showing up pretty much it's an
amazing accomplishment I think the
reason James thing took off around here
in the states I think was because there
were some people just going there and
doing their first Iron Man with him and
it became like a community event yeah
you know partly because
he he had to do the run slow and that
made it more accessible so it's almost
like the injury that James had that
forced him to do it a certain way it'd
be interesting that it would be slow no
matter what though yeah right you're
you're doing those marathons pretty slow
if you're doing it 150 days yeah in a
row yeah so it's like it it opens itself
up to kind of a community experience
fair enough um but I'm looking forward
to meeting him and and learning more and
and hopefully sharing it uh with all of
you on the show very exciting what else
do you want to talk about you know did
you hear about Kristen harilla I know
it's not on here but uh she's the
Norwegian climber that just broke
um Nirmal purges record for again all
the 8 000 meter peaks in the shortest
amount of time I think it's just over
three months you know uh Nims did six
months which which took a record from
seven years to like six months and then
Kristen was trying to do it last year
and got stymied couldn't get into Tibet
and so finally got the paperwork so she
still did all 14 of or I think there's
14 of them yeah 14. um of the 8 000
meter Peaks but she couldn't do them in
the time so she didn't get the record
and so she's she basically got her
paperwork lined up and did her first one
in Tibet so got that done and then fired
them all off and so she broke Nim's
record
um she originally financed this attempt
by selling her condo I think it was or
her or her home in Norway I talked to
her once
um when I was doing the
um lock the sherpa story and I talked to
her about how hard it is for female
climbers
um you know Mountaineers especially to
to make a living and to get sponsorship
and so she's perfect example you haven't
really heard about this even though it's
big news in Norway it didn't really hit
part of the reason that's why this is
why like maybe you would have read about
this in the New York Times sports
section yeah I mean in an article
written there was an article about her
when she was doing it going for the
record the first time and then you know
there was that story and so I would have
thought they'd do a follow-up but part
of the reason they didn't is because
it's kind of in flux over there
um but yeah exactly so I just wanted to
give her props because we've covered
I've covered Nims before and I just want
to give Kristen props pretty amazing and
you can find her on Instagram and find
all about her and uh it's an amazing
accomplishment I mean eight fourteen
eight thousand meter peaks in three
months yeah that's pretty nuts gnarly
good for her yeah congratulations that's
amazing now she says she's not gonna do
them for a while she's not 28 in two
years I understand yeah I understood we
should also mention because in the past
this was never mentioned she wasn't
alone she had a whole team and one
member of her team tenjin Sherpa was
kind of her primary partner in crime on
this a guide helped fix the everything
that she needed to be done right hand
man they took every step together and
they did l14 Peaks together so he also
did it in 92 days so it's not just
Kristen's record now it's Kristen and
tenjin sherpa's record dumb question but
how come they don't share the record
then how come it's her I think they do
okay I think they do that's where I
misspoke I think they do share it you
know because but you know I think they
do yeah interesting yeah well congrats
that's a amazing accomplishment yeah
congrats to both are we going to do a
little summer entertainment Roundup
let's do it let's keep it let's do a
speed round keep it quick speed around
off the top yep we are in the middle of
a strike right now fires killed is
striking the Screen Actors Guild is
striking I know uh are we allowed to
recommend stuff uh we support labor
let's just say that we support labor I'm
sorry I did do like an event for Netflix
around deepest
are you some kind of like scab I didn't
but you recorded that also like being in
a documentary is not a sag thing you
weren't appearing as an actor but like
you know you're with big you're with big
streamer the cat that's the cast you're
in the pocket you're in the your shill
for for big streaming I'm very cheap I
come very cheap um I did do an event
like Netflix did a screening in LA and I
did an event to support Laura McGann the
filmmaker
um and so yeah I did that and I was on
and then slate did a a story about how
like they felt like the critic felt
manipulated by my deepest breath or
something and so then I was on Canadian
public radio supporting it so I have
done two things now to support Netflix
during the strike and I have felt a
little bit funny about that I will say
interesting yeah this is like a is a
weird like internal conflict in the
skolnik value set
yes but I also as much as I support the
strike and I support the actors and
writers
I mean let's not make it out like
they're coal miners okay let's see now
you're getting you're you're treading on
thin ice right now buddy there's a lot
of there's a lot of struggling Talent
right there right now there's good
reason
um for these strikes right now it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens uh there was a big meeting last
week I thought that perhaps some
resolution was on the horizon but it
remains to be seen uh in the meantime
yes we support the writers we support
the actors I hope that they can find a
way to resolve this quickly because we
love our content in the meantime I think
we can still celebrate the product of
their labor without
being 100 I think a lot of what's
interesting though sorry to step on your
words but
um you know a lot of like actors won't
do podcasts now well they won't do
podcasts to promote a certain movie or
show right right they won't do
interviews they won't do press junkets
they're not showing up at premieres
um so it'll be interesting to see what
happens in podcast landia because
there's a lot of celebrity driven shows
out there that are reliant on booking
you know actors as their guests uh and I
think there's carve outs or cutouts I
think there's a there's something you
know kind of in between the letter of
the law and the spirit of the law in
terms of what they can and can't do like
if you're promoting a book you can come
on and do that as long as you're kind of
talking about that but you can't come on
uh any kind of press Outlet to promote
like a show or or a movie right right
yeah it's it's all in in uh in flux
right and you try to get like approval
or something from the union it is
interesting to see like and not only
have I think like broader view on the
strike I made my joke but like it
actually has
um kind of kick-started a wave of Labor
solidarity and in the Wake there has
been Baristas that are being organized
the UPS almost went on strike and was
averted at the last minute uh the uh La
city workers are now going on strike on
Tuesday the airport's going to be all
but shut down you know like the the
hotel workers here in LA and in San
Francisco they're striking all over the
place uh I think I forget how many tens
of thousands of Workers are striking
because they can't get a fair wage and a
living wage that was the Crux of my joke
but really in reality the writers were
first kind of on this online so it's
interesting to see
writers take the lead in labor
hilarious uh yeah and we're going to
turn into France yes but I mean that's a
good that's kind of an unexpected
outcome of this of like really kind of
kickstarting Labor and I think that's
good because we have this Society that's
cleaving
The Haves and the have-nots and it's
important to like labor was the reason
that when we first had this problem in
the beginning of industrialization it
was unions that solved the problem and
created the middle class so yeah yeah
um what an intro into streaming
recommendations oh by the way watch the
bear yeah exactly right that's what I'm
getting at uh the bear is back not
exactly a news flash it's been out for a
while but you know a long time listeners
of roll on know how much we love the
bear uh season two uh was released
recently I will admit after the first I
don't know two episodes of season two I
was like I don't know man I don't know
if they've they're going to be able to
keep this thing at at the level uh that
I had come to you know expect after
season one and then it just kicked into
a new gear and it went insane and I
think that that show uh the show The
Bear is one of the finest television
shows ever made like season two of The
Bear is just off the rails good I loved
it I love it too I I preferred the first
season just because it was so fresh and
so interesting and it felt felt like so
vital
um and this there's episodes that this
season two is great so I'm not I'm not
meaning to disparage it but like I still
I think prefer as a piece of work season
one but I think I'm always that guy that
likes that I liked Atlanta season one I
kind of like the first iteration because
it's the purest kind of distillation but
I will say fishes I watched it again
last night yeah in preparation because
we might talk about it and it's like
shades of Goodfellas good I mean it is
on a level of production and and in
every facet art Direction uh obviously
the dialogue and the script the acting I
mean Jamie Lee Curtis I mean is this the
year of Jamie Lee Curtis yeah she's off
the rails I mean this is a tour to Force
episode I think it's episode six yeah
it's called fishes yeah are we doing
spoilers or not it's been out a long
time yeah I I we don't have to say
everything but like go ahead speak your
mind I mean I'm not gonna go out of my
way to spoil anything but
um if you're if you don't want anything
to be spoiled maybe fast forward through
this part
um fishes is basically a a a a an
episode that focuses on Christmas dinner
and all kinds of characters come
together and it's just Insanity ensues
like it's just chaos on a whole new
level of what you thought was possible
um rendered on film it's hilarious it's
poignant it's heartbreaking and Jamie
Lee Curtis plays The Matriarch matri Arc
of the bursados and she's the matriarch
of insanity yeah her performance is is
is is really something to behold it
requires a couple viewings to really
understand what's going on every
character plays this very unique role uh
and I think anybody who has any kind of
challenging extended family situation
who knows what it's like to go home into
a perilous uh holiday dinner event we'll
find some way to relate to one of the
characters yeah because they're all
archetypes in their own right well also
like if you've ever had a mom that has
started dinner party and it was their
idea and then like is losing their mind
as they put together this amazing thing
and is like is it was wondering why no
one's helping and all that that's this
is like that 10x like this is the right
it's not it's yeah it's uh it's at 11.
the whole thing but the I yeah the
person who's like leave me alone you
know I'm going to deliver this meal
because you know love is correlated
closely with these you know what I'm
what what you're going to be eating and
like so there's so much intensity going
into that
um while also saying why isn't anyone
helping me like it's like come here I
need help no go away leave me alone like
just you know like
let's just say I know a few people like
this my mom used to get uptight at the
end of these things and I'd be like I'd
be like I think to myself my mom
probably gonna listen to this I I think
I think to myself well this was your
idea like this right no one asked you to
do this yeah
I know so you know I I've had many
versions of this dinner that are
probably at a six or maybe a six and a
half and this is at an 11. it's just
amazing it's just it's a murderer's row
of talent like the the co-stars that
show up in this episode you got Bob
Odenkirk John Bernthal who's just
electric Sarah Paulson the cool cousin
who got out who comes back to let
everyone know that there is an exit out
of this you know this this uh insane
asylum
um and then low-key John Mulaney just
like stealing the entire episode with
his you know deadpan humor I just I I
mean it's extraordinary I thought it's
the best thing I've seen him in I like
it's the most fun I mean I obviously
he's a great talent but like well he's
never has he ever even had the
opportunity to do something like that
maybe not like that's what I mean like
and it's so period and like the art is
so good everything speaks to it moment
and it speaks to the pathos that you
understand why karmi is Carmi you
understand why uh Richie is Rich you see
it all kind of happen it's like it
speaks to everything you've been
wondering about these people that's
what's so it's the origin story for all
of these characters and you know Julie
hadn't watched the bear so after I
finished season two we I went back and
started from the beginning of season one
and you see from the very first episode
everything is established the the the
drawing of the Bear Restaurant is like
on the wall that burn thought you know
like the exchange with Bernthal in in uh
in fishes and you know the the clock
Motif like that gets hammered home with
Jamie Lee Curtis and the you know the
alarm that's constantly going off and
the attention to like the ticking clock
and the pressure cooker of what it's
like to be in a kitchen to prepare a
meal like all those seeds are planted in
the early episodes of season one and
then when you get to fishes you're like
oh you see it all like played out
beautiful it's it's it is beautiful and
and and and and like like a bomb going
off like it's like it's amazing I I
agree with you like John Bernthal like I
mean come on like why isn't he in
everything like he's unbelievable he's
he increasingly isn't everything yes
there's a reason yeah but like I mean
incredible uh the emotion that these
actors go through and you and I just
want to say one thing about what I think
is interesting about this show and I'm
not like a film School guy and I'm not
that well-versed in structure uh in
terms of of production but I've noticed
a couple things
uh two different shows but the HBO show
it's uh Euphoria has this thing where
it's like reality at 120 and because of
that it's so original and no one really
else is doing that like reality at 120
125 is so intense and you feel that as a
viewer I don't particularly with that
show enjoy the experience of watching it
but I could see why people are just
captivated by it because it's so
original and in this show obviously
they're not the first people to do it
the Creator is not the first person to
do it but I feel like when I'm watching
it
the actors know to step on each other's
lines and so I don't know how it's
written on the page but they're they're
on purpose not listening not waiting for
the other actor to finish and that gives
it such a even though it's unnatural
like if you ask them to do it they're
probably their first chance they'd want
to give everyone space to say their
lines and they'd want to listen and
that's how you think about it but in
reality people are just it's messy
especially an environment like that that
episode it's it's throughout the show
but that episode really shows it and it
creates this speed and and organic feel
and power and I just think it's really
interesting because you don't see it in
a lot of in a lot of shows and I think
that's one of the hidden secrets to this
show but it's authentic to the dynamic
of this 100 it's not like an artificial
technique it's just like this is how
these people communicate yeah right
right no one's listening to anybody
everybody's kind of set in their way
they're all shouting at each other right
you know it's it's bananas
um how do you feel about the facts
wait the facts come on I love them come
on the baseball cards yeah well Maddie
Matheson who plays one of the facts the
main facts guys the main facts he's in
truth a uh like a Toronto Chef like a
celebrated Toronto Chef he's not an
actor I think he's the guy
the heavy set guy with the tattoo he's
all the tattoos and all that kind of
stuff I love him he's not really an
actor and I guess the guy who played the
other fact that was his first time
acting he was he was a crew member I
don't know what he did really true or
whatever
um
they're hitting up mullaney for like 500
bucks for their baseball card thing and
they're like do you have 500 he's like
yes I have 500 I'm a 43 year old man
that's like incredible stuff it's
amazing but I will say as as wild as
fishes was The Following episode Forks
is definitely my favorite
um in the whole series uh this is the
episode where
Richie goes to stage at a um at a you
know fancy restaurant and he goes on
this Arc and that character played by
Evan Moss uh Bacharach is just I mean
that guy is Lord like that his
performance in that episode and you know
it kind of realization that he has in
his ability to understand that his gift
is service
and it comes through the messenger in
that is the guy who got sober um who
says I'm here
to serve and I'm grateful to be here
like and he conveys to Richie
um how his life had changed as a result
of sobriety and Richie is in a place
where he's able to hear that and
understand that he too has that thing
that makes him come alive and that light
bulb moment for him changes everything
when he returns to the bear and is able
to participate
in that community on a whole nother
level than he could have previously and
I just thought there was so much heart
and Beauty in that episode like that's
the one that as as exciting as fishes is
the episode that follows is the one that
really
um has stayed with me yeah so one is
Like a Rock and Roll concert in the 70s
or like a wild Funk Party and the other
one is like an Ambiance kind of like
experience because it I think is that
the same one that they're in uh
Copenhagen doesn't go back and forth
between Copenhagen or is that just a
different my thing too yeah it's been
like a couple months since I got [__]
well there was the the pastry chef guy
who goes to Copenhagen maybe that's a
different that's a different one okay
but this one too it feels a lot more
it's more ambient it's like it's not
like it's kinetic you know feel that
it's all internal can't maintain that
level of intensity every episode so I
think going into season two they realize
like hey we gotta let the sink breathe a
little bit I agree we can choose our
moments we can have of our fishes but
what are we doing in between and that's
the real heart and connective tissue
that makes it all come together and it's
like a it's like a recipe in the kitchen
like how they're baking all these
episodes to create this you know this
extraordinary dish yes
um that I think is very thoughtful and
intentional and 100 it's like it shows
the range of the creative power in this
team that put it together because the
fact that it's all compelling but
they're all delivered so differently
usually there's a flavor you know this
one it can go any different way yeah and
I don't know that I've ever seen another
television show where from the jump from
the get-go I'm immediately so invested
in these characters and and and and
emotionally connected to them that's
like a magic trick so Christopher Storer
who created the show has done an
extraordinary job with this with this
with this with this uh series I can't
wait to see what what happens in season
three and Richie's and Richie's uh kind
of big moment at the end of forks
there's a great Cameo
um yeah we won't spoil yeah fantastic
one scene I mean they're great together
yeah incredible yeah incredible stuff
yeah um is there anything that needs to
be said about barberheimer yeah has it
all been written and said Adam
well did you read about Nolan's reported
deal no he gets 20 of first gross hmm
that's quite a deal you make it for
himself
uh I think Oppenheimer is at 500 million
Barbies at 1 billion collectively Nolan
and Gerwig have saved the the in theater
movie experience the relevancy of movies
do we feel bad for Tom Cruise no you
can't feel bad for Tom Cruise
he's in the background like gnashing his
teeth wondering how come he's not the
lead story if he is then I do feel bad
for him I bet he is I bet he's so
goddamn competitive that guy no way he's
like right well I know he was pissed
about the IMAX windowing because he
wanted mission impossible to have have
kind of purview with the IMAX theaters
um and that went uh Oppenheimer and
Mission Impossible was amazing but then
once it was the barberheimer thing like
it was almost like we forgot that
mission impossible happened and this guy
rode his motorcycle off a mountain yeah
he's probably off base jumping somewhere
so I'm not sure he's paying attention to
us but I will say this I'm on his team
when it comes you don't think he's
listening Adam no I I I I when it comes
to why is Oppenheimer on IMAX I'm 100
with Tom Cruise like I just I watched it
I'm not saying it's not a good movie
I I am wondering why here comes the hot
taste I am wondering why a movie that is
centered around business meetings is on
IMAX I just don't understand it like I
legit I mean the one visual was great
I'm I legit don't understand why it had
to be on IMAX
i i i respectfully disagree I was at the
very first screening of Oppenheimer at
at the Chinese Theater Thursday at five
o'clock I was in like the fourth row at
the IMAX 70 millimeter experience now
let me tell you something uh if you are
at the very first screen of Oppenheimer
at the Chinese Theater at the iMac 70
millimeter experience this is a theater
full of nerds like this is the ultimate
film nerd audience
come to life yes right and I could not
have been happier or more thrilled to be
there uh uh Tyler and Trapper uh bought
tickets for this was like the Father's
Day gift so I cut out of the studio
early to make it over there and it's
like you're that you're you're you're
you're getting you're you're you're
sitting down and everyone's well I'm
gonna watch it in 70 millimeter but then
tomorrow I'm gonna go see it at the
other theater so I can compare you know
like every wow film nerd talk wow that's
big but I could tell you that the
tallness of the iMac screen
um really changes the experience and I
think this film is a masterpiece and I
will never forget the experience of
being in that theater to see it for the
very first time so I disagree with you I
think it's a tour de force of a movie
okay um and I think it deserves to be
seen in that format and yes there are a
lot of white men talking in rooms uh a
lot of meetings but who else could make
that utterly riveting
other than Christopher Nolan I mean he
created a thriller out of like men
having conversations a lot of meetings
there's the Trinity test that's exciting
yeah that's great I like that part yes I
think uh Cillian Cillian is it Cillian
Killian Killian Killian just looks at
you he's like there's a lot of Killian
looking at the camera well he's I mean
he I mean that performance okay he's in
a whole he's a whole other one people
are gonna think that I'm just bad
mouthing and I'm not going to Robert
Downey Jr is amazing uh I think Emily
Blunt is fantastic you'll see them both
get nominated I think obviously
Killian's gonna get nominated
um I thought I love Matt Damon and
everything he's in so this is not me not
liking it I'm just gonna say there was
snoring in my theater as many as nerds
as wearing a while there was there was
audible snoring in my theater for the
last hour
interesting as you might expect in a
long meeting yeah interesting uh yeah I
did that was not my experience
um I loved everything about it uh I
thought it was interesting there's just
unreal performances the filmmaking is
extraordinary it gives us the meme we
didn't know that we needed that that
image of Benny safti uh lathering
himself with sunscreen and putting on
the goggles that was very funny is the
ultimate meme that you could throw up on
the Internet uh when you're you know you
know that that Trope of like there's
drama happening I'm gonna grab my
popcorn this is now uh Market corrected
that you can just put that image of many
safety there like I'm getting ready to
see the thing yeah and then Einstein I
loved him whoever played that was great
and and uh but one thing I didn't like
that I wished was in it was and it's
hard to say I wish something more was in
a three-hour movie but uh like the
uranium came from Australia and had to
be come through on ships through the
Pacific Theater like to me that's
interesting I would like to see like how
that happened you know like you have to
travel through the Pacific Theater from
Australia in the middle of the war to
beat the Nazis I just felt like story
wise there could have been ways to up
the action and reduce the meetings
that's all well it was a it was a lens
into the mind of one man right right
like you know Rob Oppenheimer wasn't
even in charge of the whole Manhattan
Project he was just in charge of Los
Alamos right so it was a portrait of a
torture genius through the lens of
Christopher Nolan who
perhaps he considers himself a torture
genius uh with the message of like
shouldn't we just leave Geniuses alone
and let them be Geniuses right yes
there's a little bit of that that's true
how much of that is autobiographical I
don't know but I think Nolan is very
interesting yes because he you know he
he lives a true
artist's life like he doesn't have a
cell phone he doesn't even have an email
address you can't email the guy do you
believe he doesn't have a cell phone
how's he listening to me I know well he
has I'm sure he has a Phalanx of
assistance okay right but he goes out of
his way to not be influenced by the
cacophony of culture and society and
distraction and I think there's
something incredibly courageous and
laudable about that in 2023 that he can
be a guy without an email address who
has his production I think he bought the
home next door to where he lives and
that's his production office he works
with his wife
um
and everything that he does
is about creating credibility so that he
can create outside the influence of the
studio system obviously he's Partners
you know with the studio system to make
his movies but by delivering
extraordinary movies under budget and on
time he has a lot more freedom also due
to the extraordinary success of his
movies to kind of not be bothered by
stuff that other filmmakers would be
bothered and I think that that is a very
intentional career move that he's you
know doubled down on time and time again
over the course of his career so that he
can make these kinds of movies and I
think there's something really
instructive about that lifestyle choice
that in 2023 feels very anachronistic
yes but I think is also extremely wise
and and certainly crucial to his success
if you can do it it's it's I think there
is something to be said about being off
the main and having an artistic View and
an objective view of how things are
going especially as a Storyteller I will
say you can't not respect him obviously
I have a great a great amount of respect
for him great amount of respect for
Greta Gerwig and what they've done but
um I will say I don't believe everything
a filmmaker a guy whose whole point is
to create an illusion I don't believe
everything they say about how they live
their life when they're doing press for
their movie so like it creates myths you
know the myth of Christopher Nolan right
yeah right I understand what you're
saying yeah uh I don't know
um we won't know we could test that uh
which brings me I'm gonna email him
right now I've extracted a few insights
I wanted to share from this movie before
we move on and one of one of them is
related to what you just said which is
there is the theory of how uh
Christopher Nolan lives his life but
what is the practice right and this is
the message of the movie is it not Adam
Theory can only take you so far indeed
right you have to put Theory into action
uh next
I also mentioned this one a minute ago
we should leave Geniuses alone to be
Geniuses this is the message
why do you keep emailing me and texting
me I gotta stop bothering you right I I
needed to see this movie twice in order
to really grock that Adam
um also being a lefty does not work well
with the military industrial complex
especially as as far Lefty as he was
yeah yes yes
um don't mock powerful people in public
hearings it always comes back to bite
you later maybe you were asleep during
that part no I stayed away okay I mean I
gotta see I wanted to see uh you know I
gotta see who else was in it
um
Robert Downey Jr yeah no the other guy
no who's on the other Oscar winner in
that scene why am I switching uh Remy
oh Remy Malek yes yeah coming in for
that one scene at the end I found him to
be distracting with his weird eyeball
stuff you know there's something very
strange about that guy uh he crushed
that one speech but in the scene earlier
where he the first time where he drops
the clipboard I was like I it took me
out of the movie I will give you that
bad first scene great second scene how
about this one no matter what you think
of the movie Adam yeah we all know if
you know anything about Oppenheimer that
at some point he's got to drop the line
now I have become death destroyer of
worlds right this is what if you don't
know anything about Oppenheimer that
might be the one thing you know like
this is how we thought of what he had
wrought on the world well he he but
you're thinking going into the movie
where is this going to happen right when
is he going to say it who's he going to
say it to here's the creative Choice
let's do it while Florence Pugh Is
straddling him naked yes and he utters
the line now that my friend is a strong
Creator reading reading Sanskrit and
yeah that is a big love Choice yes to
make as a filmmaker he was a real
Bohemian well he was a ladies man my
next point right who knew who knew
certainly not me those baby blues I'm
not sure that she yeah right who knew he
was he seems like he would sleep with
anybody's wife that was at the dinner
party there was a lot of that I know I
know and and where did it get him Adam
he got him married to Emily Blunt that's
true uh you know all of these
relationships were from well that's the
biggest critique public critique of the
movie is you don't actually even though
you know that it affects him deeply and
he feels like in some ways he's failed
as a human being
you don't actually see the damage and
that was intentional and Christopher
Nolan's spoken about that but that is
something I'm still hearing about online
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure also not
notable for writing strong female
characters Nolan yeah really is that
right yeah I thought that was fabulous
she was good but they could have given
her a little bit more to do but it was
nice to see her stand up but but her job
was secondary in her support of him of
course right of course her story and
that's also speaks to the time a little
bit too my final thing and this bugs me
more than anything is that Nolan needs a
new sound mixer I don't know about you
but I find
70 percent of the dialogue inaudible in
his movies I had the same problem with
tenet at first I thought it was the
theater or maybe sitting too close to
the screen
um but after a second viewing I found it
to be the same there's a certain
muffledness with the dialogue right and
his movies are so complex and you need
to really hear every single thing that
everyone's saying just to not get passed
by so you can be locked into the
progression of the story and he adds
this extra layer of difficulty on top of
it by making it difficult to understand
what they're saying yeah I thought maybe
I was just getting old but this is a
thing like I noticed it in tenant I did
some research on it like a lot of people
have been commenting on this so I don't
know why he does that
but um but maybe maybe don't do it next
time yeah don't do it and but I I love
the movie the good news though
he didn't make meg2 so you'll be able to
hear everything that happens in meg2
real clear the dialogue will be very
audible on that movie I'm sure all right
so you had mentioned that Christopher
Nolan makes 20 of gross off the top
which means that I've read well that who
knows assuming that's true he's already
made north of 100 million dollars yes so
the question is will he deploy that 100
million dollars to buy a cell phone
possibly maybe not we don't know
probably you're so cynical you don't but
you believe he has a cell phone and he's
lying the whole time no I believe he has
created the myth of Christopher Nolan
I'm saying that but I will say okay yeah
but I will say our friend Chris Evans
over here didn't have a cell phone for a
long time also emails under an alias and
he I think I think maybe the first time
you emailed me under an alias you said
well this is actually me blah blah blah
and uh and then subsequently you emailed
me but I'd forgotten the name that you
were using or whatever and I didn't know
who this person was and you were trying
to communicate do you what happened yeah
and I just blew it off yeah come here
and tell that story
Chris Evans everybody he's back see how
I pulled him back in
Christopher no phone you don't believe
him here's here's the thing
when you when if for me to believe that
you're so analog that you're off the
beat
you don't tell me you don't have an
email address what you say is I have
only have an AOL email address if you
say I only have an AOL email address
then you're like someone's Grandpa and
you're really analog because you're
really off the beat but if you just say
I don't have an email address that could
be some [__] so they say Rich will
know this if you spot it you got it yeah
where's that from I don't know from you
Shakespeare from the rooms sometimes
people said oh that yeah
so you say some people come in here and
they want you to think one thing about
them or another thing about them if you
spot it you got it Adam right well they
yeah I mean basically yeah that is
totally not me at all another way of
saying it that is you can't transmit
something you haven't got right so if
somebody is authentically sharing from
their heart you cannot you know right
and if they're they're if they're
bullshitting you if your radar is even
slightly attuned you can tell that's all
I'm saying and so I my point is that I
don't think most directors in a
publicity scenario this is not speaking
about him personally are going to be are
going to be able to be revealing like
that because they want especially a guy
who wants to keep his kind of creative
potion going he would have an uh a
motivation to not but if you're like
just some writer guy on a podcast I'm
not fake so you think one of the most
creative Geniuses of our time yeah yeah
has Cuts come up with this ruse of not
having a phone to promote his amazing
film yes thank you okay thank you for
concisely making the point that it's
true I was
um I like how he dodged his own uh email
Alias question yeah also still don't pay
my own phone you don't
yeah that's like a uh that's a Rich Man
Poor Man thing either you're so poor you
don't pay it or you're so rich someone
else pays it no
no who was insistent that I had a phone
and I said I'm not going to get one so
he got me one and he still pays the
bills
maybe you can be that guy for
Christopher Nolan Adam Christopher if
you're listening and I know you are
you'll pay his cell phone bill forever I
got your cell phone bill and I'm sorry I
said that thing about the snoring people
it's their fault something they were
going through I liked it I was there for
the experience I'm just saying
there was a few too many meetings maybe
and there was you know now you're coming
off week with that back pedal like hold
your either you know hold your ground
you know what I mean all right we just
did a movie podcast we're done we're not
going to talk about any of these other
stuff let's see some listener questions
let's do it this is from Matthew who's
calling all the way in from South Korea
hi this is Matthew uh calling from South
Korea uh I just finished my 18th year of
teaching as a middle and high school
math teacher uh I taught in public and
private schools in the United States and
private international schools in Mexico
and South Korea
as a teacher I value teaching students
to thank problem solve understand why
things work and solving non-routine
problems
while also items such as value and
mental health being good people grit and
empathy
I have three education related questions
feel free to answer whichever you like
when I'm asking them in order of
importance to me
my first question leaving it fairly
open-ended what are your thoughts on
secondary education system in the U.S
it could be the status of American
Education or what do you think are
important skills or challenges that
teachers and students should focus on
second question if you were given a
commencement speech what would your
message be
and third question
how would you apply James clear's one
percent rule for teachers that want to
continue to improve their craft or
potentially find new positions in
education related careers that may
demand additional skills such as
leadership that are typically absent
from a day-to-day job for a teacher
thank you wow a three-parter from
Matthew yes in South Korea uh I I think
I'll tackle the first two parts the
third part I'm not sure I have a worthy
answer to maybe maybe you do no I don't
know what the one what clears one
percent rule is you know I think there's
a lot to be said about secondary
education at least in the United States
as an outdated model that was shaped by
the needs of uh the emerging
uh capitalist Trend that we've been on
basically what happened was the
Industrial Revolution and when that
happened and gained momentum
industrialists required skilled and
disciplined workers to they needed a
continual supply of these people to meet
the demands of their growing industry
Industries and the education system was
like its feeder program and it was
really developed out of a need a desire
to cater to those industrialists by
emphasizing or creating a curriculum
that would create good workers you know
workers who could be punctual obedient
efficient
and so the whole infrastructure of
secondary education was oriented around
you know teaching people what they
needed to know in order to be good
Factory workers essentially and here we
are in 2023 have we really changed this
system not really right we're all
walking around I've said this before
with super computers in our pocket that
can answer any fact based question that
you could possibly have have we now have
all of these incredibly powerful llms
that you know take that even a step
further what the world is going to look
like in three to five years who knows
but certainly those tools are going to
get refined and enhanced which begs the
question of what are we doing in the
classroom right should we be teaching
people in a way where we're prioritizing
the memorization of facts and the
answering of rope questions that these
computers can do for us
I think that the emphasis should be
shifted to focus on some of the things
that he is already seems to be teaching
in his classroom maybe because he's in
South Korea and not in the United States
where
um he would be much more restricted in
what his curriculum look looks like but
you know I really think that education
needs to evolve beyond the fact-based
memorization Paradigm that we've had for
too many decades and needs to focus on
about developing self-esteem how about
teaching leadership how about helping
young people learn how to tap into their
creative voice and express themselves
how about team building how do you build
a team how do you work within a team how
do you problem solve as an individual
but also as a member of a team as a
leader or as uh you know just a just a
member of a larger team like when you go
out into the world
what's going to distinguish you from an
AI or you know uh you know something
that that could supplant you in the
workforce it's your creativity it's your
ability to look at a problem and solve
it with a perspective that is fresh and
new and you know I think it's your
ability to work with other people to
understand how to respect uh other
people as well in the workforce and with
a level of self-esteem that
um is going to empower you to tackle
difficult things and learn and grow in
all the various ways that we need you to
you know so I don't know
it seems pretty evident to me I don't
know that I'm seeing a lot of that and
it doesn't seem to be a lot of evolution
in the secondary educational system
and you have a young person who I do I'm
not there yet we're not there yet
although he did take a Polaroid uh self
self Polaroid selfie when we weren't
looking yesterday and it looks like I
could see his teen self his disaffected
teen self in this too close Polaroid of
my cute little Naval gazing uh you know
sort of yeah like shut up Dad yeah you
have to see him happening
um I think what you're saying is well
said and you know how do you get there
from here I don't even really know I
couldn't answer because I don't know the
status of current secondary education
because I don't have a child that's
there it's been a while for me
um you you know are shepherding people
through school that like two you had two
that just kind of one that just went
through it and one that is going through
it right yeah so you you have a perfect
lens on this I will say that one thing I
don't like is the politicism political
politicization politicization politics
politicization you know when we get
older it gets harder to say words like
that of everything yeah and the fact
that now
parents are like having fights at school
board meetings is appalling and so that
we had that intellect Temecula we had
that in Glendale here just in Southern
California and these fights are going
whatever the reason I don't really care
what the reason is it's like it shows me
that anytime you give teachers latitude
it's going to be fought at some point on
either side and that's a problem right
so for me it's like my thing is Teachers
should be paid more they should be given
more autonomy we should take the
emphasis off standardized testing but we
can't have the hegemony of the mob kind
of dictate what is taught at a
particular community so all of those
things are very complex and there's
people who know a lot more about them
than me but that's what concerns me
about secondary education from someone
who hasn't been in the teeth of it for a
while yeah so yeah so you're not into
Banning books
no I think all books should be available
at all times yeah all books I mean I
think the system is set up to create
people who are really good at taking
tests right that's what it rewards it
doesn't reward creativity or thinking
outside the box and I think those are
skills that are becoming more and more
valuable and and that needs to get
priced in to this whole system I don't
know how you do that I don't know the
answer to that I mean let's let's keep
it real like for so long our public
education system was was basically built
on the fact that there was a glass
ceiling in place and women couldn't
really get high paying jobs in the
corporate world and so the place that
high-powered really intelligent women
could do well was as teachers in schools
and so that happened for Generations so
that's why you know my mother was a
teacher in school she's like a brilliant
woman and so and there's a lot of
teachers that are still brilliant now
this is not [__] on teachers but
what I'm saying is there was a built-in
kind of funnel of talent to schools that
now there isn't because they could they
have other choices yeah and so you know
we have to pay teachers more I I think
you know given the the condition of
cities we have to pay police officers we
have to pay people more so you get
talent that that is a top talent so you
can compete really and get and get
people that that that can help us move
in that General in that direction yeah I
agree with that but at the same time you
can pay you could pay teachers a lot
more and obviously a great teacher can
make a huge difference but if they're
stuck within the confines of a system
that doesn't allow them to have any
flexibility with the curriculum or the
manner in which they teach that's only
going to go so far so it's a systemic
problem as much as anything else and
then you know to the second question of
the commencement speech I just jotted
down a couple of thoughts and you know
on that note I mean I think in terms of
ideas that I like to communicate to
young people first and foremost is to
invest in your own creativity and not
get caught up in the confined structures
of the system that is trying to push you
in a certain Direction go to this school
go to that school get this kind of job
you know people who are very good at
school who are very good at taking tests
tend to also be rule followers and they
become very good at figuring out how to
be upwardly Mobile in that situation I
was one of those people it was only in
later years that I realized like why was
I doing any of this because I hadn't
paused to reflect upon what it was that
I wanted to do or who I wanted to be so
I'm always impressing upon young people
to engage with that process earlier in
life than I did and sometimes it's
difficult because you are in a system
that's telling you this is what's
important getting a good grade on this
test or interviewing for this job and it
takes courage and a presence of mind to
kind of pause for a moment and say okay
yes but also I need to do this for
myself long term so I think that's
important and that will help you
entertain opportunities that are outside
of your comfort zone and those
experiences while you face obstacles and
fail and fall on your face and have
these experiences over time will help
you discover who you are and what's
important to you and in the meantime I
think it's important for young people to
consciously give their energy to things
that really light them up and excite
them irrespective of whatever
external forces are telling you you
should or you shouldn't do like if
something really means something to you
and gets you excited and gives you
energy when you get out of bed that's
something that you should fertilize and
cultivate in your own life it doesn't
mean it has to be a job but I think
there's something in that that's
communicating to you who you are and
it's important to give your attention to
that and sometimes that means breaking
free of the expectations of other people
and those social
strictures can be
suffocating and very difficult to escape
from and I think developing an awareness
around that and the extent to which
those externalities are controlling your
decision making or in unduly influencing
the decisions you're making about what
you're going to do with your life uh are
really important to consider
I also
on a conservative note think that it's
important to learn discipline and the
value of hard work and the value of a
dollar like there is a certain
entitlement with uh you know some
aspects of the younger generation where
they think they should just Waltz in
somewhere and get a high-paid job and
get to do what they want to do and work
from home and and and you know basically
go on expensive vacations whenever they
feel like it and you know it's just not
reality so I think there's disabusing
people of that notion and getting them
connected to uh the idea that if you
want to do something no matter what it
is it's going to be difficult and you
know kind of acclimating yourself to
that earlier in life I think is
important as well so experience life say
yes to Adventure accumulate experiences
and along the way figure out you and
then commit to being the best version of
that authentic you that is your mission
I love that
boom part three I got nothing to say oh
I was waiting for you to go on no I got
nothing I I don't know what the one he's
been a teacher for 18 years what can I
tell this guy yeah
yeah I know you should give us how do we
fix it yeah I know what's happening in
Korea I don't know I don't know I
appreciated that question that was good
anytime we could talk about the
education system I think is important
um and uh let's move on to the next one
hey Rich and Adam uh my name is Zach I'm
22 years old I'm originally from
Bethesda Maryland and right now I'm in
the Army and I'm living in Korea so my
question was
um how do you navigate pursuing
challenges and embracing obstacles from
a state of completion uh and you know
feeling like you're enough so for a bit
of context here
um I've been really into Eastern
philosophy philosophy lately so I've
been reading a lot of Alan Watts and
practicing mindfulness meditation
um but at the same time sometimes it
feels like the more I consume Eastern
philosophy uh
well it encourages you know a state of
calming Clarity it also seems to reduce
ambition a little bit along with you
know my desire to like do hard things
so I was just curious how you guys
approach this divide and you know these
different states of
of being and um yeah thank you guys for
all the great work you do on the podcast
I'm a big fan thanks how about Zach
dropping in with like the ultimate you
know struggle of mankind right spiritual
Warrior versus doing I mean this is this
is the [__] right like this is the whole
ball game is it not before we unpack
that though you know I'm from Bethesda
but I think I I knew you were like so I
thought you were Silver Spring you're
Bethesda no I grew up in Bethesda okay
and and uh Zach being
um from the Army reminded me
sort of related so when I was in high
school one of the jobs that I had
was uh delivering pizza and I delivered
pizza for this pizza delivery company
called it was sort of like a Domino's
thing but it was just a one like
family-owned one shop thing it was
called postal pizza oh which is a
terrible name because it's like we're as
slow as the male like I don't get it
yeah but back then the male was
perspective it was called postal Pizza
this was the greatest job though I love
this job because basically you just
drive around and listen to music and
then you get to knock on people's doors
and then look into their house and see
how people live like when I was 17 or
whatever I thought it was great you were
a Postmates but what was great about
postal pizza was I mean this is like I
don't know 87 or something yes uh it was
it was connected to a video rental store
okay so you could call up and you order
your pizza but you could also order a
movie so deliver the pizza and the VHS
tape that's awesome which was pretty
cool that's I've never heard of that
before one time Ted Koppel came in
walked in that was the big moment come
on very summer ordered his pizza in
person but anyway how but here's the
thing like uh what how great is his what
his hair I know is it real I think it's
real I think it's real it's quite cool
is it not yeah anyway
um a lot of the orders would come from
the Naval Base uh where like ni NIH is
and um what is it Walter Reed like when
the president goes to the hospital where
so there's a naval base there the fact
that Zach's in the Army just reminded me
of this so 70 of the pizza orders were
like the enlisted guys at the at the
naval base in Bethesda which is weird
because there's no it's not on the water
like I don't I don't know what they were
what goes on at that Naval Base but
anyway they order a lot of pizza and
they were not great tippers that's
that's my favorite takeaway I don't
remember that but you know yeah
let's try to let it read that out
breathe it out okay
maybe Zach is a good Tipper though
we don't know we don't know it depends
on the more he more and more Alan Watts
he listens
like hey bro don't look at me like you
need a tip it doesn't really matter
doesn't really matter bro what can we
tell Zach about the the tension between
being and doing Adam I'm going to let
you take a stab at this first yeah I
have some thoughts but well you know
it's not like it's not like it's not
like hey man should I go to college or
not like this is the struggle of man
right right like so when I first started
to get into reading the data Ching I
felt like going with the flow was a kind
of a path of least resistance thing and
and so yes it was like a more it's okay
to be a little more passive and let the
world have you know like flow with the
world
um which I guess you can be interpreted
as as as reduction of ambition as in
you're not trying to actively do
something against the momentum that is
just existing that you have to kind of
merge with but the more I read read it
now I just see it as a different thing I
see it as how you're
um taming the mind and that is separate
from your goals and Ambitions and so the
how how you train your mind and how you
come to balance
um in your mind does that does that mean
you're not doing hard things it doesn't
mean you don't have ambition in your
life it means like principles like
humility
um adaptability perseverance which to me
are core their core in the Dao their
core to mindfulness
um those things are really important to
doing hard things so the way I look at
that is that the when you're when you're
first reading into philosophy it's easy
to kind of get the hook you get hooked
by that passive not passive I wouldn't
even pass it on the right word but you
get hooked by that kind of feeling of
flow because that's what Hooks you right
it's like oh wow that we are so small
and that we are in awe of how small we
are and how beautiful and vast the world
is and the energy that's flowing all
around us and so we're in all of that
then comes then comes the terror but
then but then you get into or you're a
householder you know like now you're in
a different place like when I was kind
of a pebble getting kicked around the
world doing the travel stuff it's easy
to stay in that small space but when
you're raising a family and you have
other you have you're being tugged on in
a million directions these kind of
smaller but actually deeper realizations
of just remain humble remain adaptable
and persevere which to me is everything
um that's I think where you can click in
to to continue to have your ambition
continue to do those hard things just
look at it at that next level or maybe
maybe just look at you know the way I do
it is I don't I don't read a whole book
with data Chang I might read one verse
every day for weeks
um until I'm kind of feel like I got one
one part of that lesson so that's just
that way I look at this particular
question yeah well said the idea that
being or investing in a state of being
brings a certain presence of mind and
mindfulness to
um to the doing I think is what you're
saying yeah right I think when I said
Terror what I what I meant by that is
there is you know the more the more that
you invest in this journey of being the
more you realize uh the the
um
the fractured illusion of identity right
the attachments that you've made between
what you do and who you are so here we
have a guy who's in the Army who's in a
very regimented
um situation sort of dynamic for his
life in which uh there's a priority
placed on doing hard things overcoming
obstacles in a certain way and there's
an association of masculinity and
success that comes with that and when
you start going down the Alan Watts
being Rabbit Hole uh you start to
deconstruct that identity and that's
scary right like well who am I right
like the futility of it right right yeah
exactly so I think this is kind of where
you know if he finds himself right now
yes I was reading that yeah you know
this idea that uh oh well if I'm not you
know in the army or I'm not like
climbing a a wall or or you know like
tackling this difficult problem then who
I'm who am I like this the more I the
the more I kind of go down this rabbit
hole it's going to rob me of that
ambition and that ambition is what I
associate with who I am and when you
start to pull the cover on that and
realize well that's something you do or
it's an attachment you have to a certain
sense of your identity that is not
actually reality that's a scary thing
right so it's like it's threatening
everything that you've constructed
in your mind about who you are so
I think that's also this amazing
opportunity right like where you can
where you can realize that there's a
greater depth and complexity
um to who you are and a dynamism to who
you are and how you show up in the world
um that is going to only expand your
life right so
I understand and appreciate the fear
that gets associated with like hey man
if I if I keep doing all this stuff like
I'm going to end up in a cave somewhere
penniless and you know all of that I
found all of those fears to actually be
false for the very reasons that you said
like the more it just it basically
provides you
um with a Clarity that helps you discern
what is worthy of your attention and
your attention is really all that you
have how you direct it where you focus
it
um is you know the most those are the
most important decisions that you make
right and the clarity that comes with
being will allow you to discard or
bypass expenditures of your time energy
focus and work that are moving away from
the person that you're working towards
or that you aspire to be so it is the
being that clarifies what is important
and what is not such that you can bring
a presence and a mindfulness to the
doing the doing doesn't fade away or go
away you can still do hard things and
you know exactly the way that you
described it but you're doing it with a
level of intentionality and an
understanding that
by placing your attention on this thing
that aligns with your values you know
that uh that that doing is worthy of the
being that you're bringing to it and
just to put a cap on it like doing hard
things we talk about that as if it's a
choice I mean the bottom line is we're
all gonna have to do hard things because
it's life right yeah life is [__]
hard like the hard things are coming you
know what I mean so it's like that's
just the way it is and um and I
understand that I get what you're saying
I think you you nailed this and I just
want to say that uh the terror it's like
reminds me of existentialism and kind of
that you can hear in Bob Dylan and and
you you read in Albert Camus
existentialist Terror that uh everything
is futile
it doesn't matter what happens but
actually that's the Liberation isn't
that nihilism no but that's the
liberation of existentialism right it
doesn't matter the outcome of a b or c
because and if you feel that way then
that allows you to be free in the action
of it and that therefore everything is
liberated right and so I feel like
there's a parallel there in eastern
philosophy in terms of as you approach
something like that you might have to do
at work it's like yes you're going to
give it your all if it doesn't go your
way you're gonna keep giving it your all
because that's what we're here for yeah
yeah let's go to Austin all right Austin
Texas let's get out of Korea for once
oh
all right
this is good see didn't you miss me I
knew you missed I know hi there this is
Brett Keenan I'm from Austin Texas and
I'm just sitting here doing the very
mundane tasks and portion of my
work which
um I feel
generally very excited by I do
experiential marketing and I'm a
consultant for a business and I really
enjoy it but
um in sort of doing my own business now
I'm just curious like with all of the
the show that you've grown and just
business in general knowing that
probably 80 percent of it is just these
boring tasks that we have to get through
and email and blah blah blah like if you
have any recommendations for how to make
the boring Parts more stimulating any
mindsets or mental reframes to feel more
invigorated and get through the sort of
not fun parts so that's my question I
hope you all have a great day thanks I
feel like Brett's question Taps into the
existentialism that you were just
talking about a minute ago yes uh you
know is there meaning is there is you
know what it what is beyond here how are
we going to you know find uh you know
some kind of purpose beyond the
mundanity and I think layered into this
question is
perhaps a uh
a less than fully mature uh appreciation
for the fact that life is not just about
leaping from one Peak experience to the
next but that in truth everything worthy
of pursuing or doing or building or
growing or working towards involves a
lot of [__] boring [__] you know and
you gotta just like Goggins would say
embrace the suck right like yes you
gotta suit up and just do the boring
[__] like you know whether it's business
especially in social media you go online
and it's just post after post about you
know success story and overnight Venture
Capital funding and product launches and
all kinds of sexy exciting stuff but
behind the scenes of anything successful
whether it's a business or a podcast or
as an athlete or an author or any
creative Endeavor there's just a lot of
really hard unsexy [__] that doesn't
travel on the internet at but is the
underlying truth in the recipe of
achieving anything worthwhile in the
world right so rather than trying to
turn those boring tasks into
just another Peak experience I think
it's reframing it and understanding that
this is just part of the journey that
you're on in the process of trying to
build something for yourself and there's
a there's kind of a powerful lesson
about life in that uh and it's back to
your attention right all you have is
your attention how are you directing
that attention and what is the
um kind of
default predisposition that you're
bringing that attention that that is
that is kind of packed on to or attached
to that attention when you have to do
boring [__] like answer emails right
yeah can you reframe it and say well
this is just this is something that I
have to do and every person who's trying
to build something similar to what I'm
trying to build has to do it as well so
can I find gratitude in it can I figure
out that this is just a piece and a
greater journey and that it's serving an
important purpose as mundane as it is
like there's no getting around it yeah
no I mean you brought up David and I
have it's so funny like how like months
after this book has come out after
working like I'm find myself
like thinking thinking of life and more
now than maybe after at all in my whole
life after having done these two books
and I can I feel like I don't know for a
fact this is how we react but I think
what he would say and and how he would
feel about this is
this boring [__] is your opportunity to
separate yourself from everybody else
doing your job
this boring [__] right here is why
everybody else comes in second or third
or fifth or eighth because this boring
[__] just bothers them to the point
where they just get half asset and give
himself permission to quit
this boring [__] is your ticket to be
the best there is in your business
I'm not going to top that so that's a
good play that's a good that's another
mic drop
courtesy of Goggins right yeah two for
Chris
one for Adam and that's a wrap
um awesome thank you uh Chris Evans for
joining us today as begrudging as you
were it was beautiful to have you I
appreciate you I love you buddy and Adam
good to be back with you man thanks for
maybe we should should we do this more
often I'm literally always available
literally I will take that to heart
um we'll be back when we're back in the
meantime uh I do not take your attention
for granted I really appreciate uh
everybody who has listened all the way
through to the end of the day yeah
you made it congratulations you started
out yeah thanking the listeners I thank
you uh for having me back and thank you
listeners for tuning in thank you Chris
for your advice and and your optimism
appreciate it yeah absolutely
all right man that's it
peace plants
[Music]